grab a drink and an axe
because i'm still angry charlize theron
won't be playing furiosa in the new mad
max film
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into netflix's the old guard
and how the ending lays the groundwork
for a potential sequel but before we get
started
make sure to like and subscribe because
i'm always coming out with new videos
theories and deep dives the old guard
follows andromacha of cythia an immortal
warrior who leads a band of mercenaries
named after the oldest currently active
regiment in the us
army they're also just old because hey
they're immortal andromeka or andy as
she's called is the oldest of the
immortals with the comic stating that
she could be born as far back as 4 500
bc
originating in scythia which is modern
day eurasia in greek mythology the
character of andromeda translates to
fighter of men and her character
represented the suffering of women
during the trojan war and he herself has
known nothing but suffering for
thousands of years
the first person she met who was
immortal like her was sentenced to spend
eternity drowning over and over again
in an iron coffin her lover was killed
on the battlefield in front of her
andy has become jaded with life and the
world in general the world can burn for
all i care
while waiting in the lobby at the hotel
andy sees on the news images of the
civil war in syria
and unrest in haiti it seems no matter
what she and the old guard does
it doesn't have any impact on the world
and we'll find out later this couldn't
be further from the truth
in order for andy to grow as a character
she'll need to realize that
life is worth living and that the old
guard does indeed serve a worthwhile
purpose for humanity at the end of act
one andy and the old guard
are set up by a man named copley he's
lured them into a trap to show this big
pharmaceutical manufacturer merrick that
immortals exist
you see copley lost his wife a few years
back and believes that if the powers of
these immortals can be studied perhaps
it can prevent diseases like the one
that took his wife's life
what he doesn't know is that merrick
doesn't care at all about helping
humanity he's in it for the money
what do you see
the nobel prize and a fair few quid to
boot
in afghanistan we meet nile freeman a
marine who finds out she is immortal as
well
unlike andy she isn't jaded by the world
believing that she can make a difference
we see her giving out candy to local
children and helping a group of women
whose town has been terrorized by a
terrorist after finding out she's
immortal the old guard are alerted to
her presence
via dreams we dream of each other they
stop when we meet
it's only when they're brought together
do these dreams stop so they believe
being together
is their destiny they join forces to
take on american copley knowing that
they can never live in peace until they
are stopped while hiding out in france
the team is attacked and joe and nicki
are captured
and he knows what it's like to lose a
team member centuries ago she lost quinn
so she makes it her mission to free joe
and nicki
perhaps hoping it will give her some
redemption but as andy booker and nile
prepare to infiltrate copley nyle says
this life isn't for her
she wants to be with her family even
though booker says it will
torture her to watch them grow old and
die everyone you love
is gonna grow old
it's gonna it's gonna suffer and it's
gonna die
andy gives her a gun and sees her off
but nile later finds the magazine is
empty
and remembers it was booker who gave it
to her she knows she has to go back
because
booker is planning to betray andy and
that's exactly what he does
he shoots andy not knowing that she's
lost her immortal power
yes the immortals can lose their power
they just don't know when
there's this great albeit awkward scene
where andy buys bandages at a local
drugstore opting to throw everything in
the bin because she's
likely never had to buy bandages before
booker has betrayed andy in the old
guard because he believes if merrick can
find a cure to extending life
then perhaps he can also find a cure to
ending theirs
for booker life has been nothing but
endless pain and suffering having to
watch his family die
and he can't even kill himself to end
the pain he wants a way out and he sees
it with merrick
booker however immediately regrets his
decision when he finds out andy can be
killed
he and her are subsequently captured
leaving only nile and copley to come to
the rescue
copley has jumped ship too realizing
merrick has gone too
far he's intending to lock up the old
guard as his prisoners forever
if that's what it takes i will carve
slices of you for years to get what i
want
nile learns that copley has been
tracking the old guard for years seeing
how their actions have impacted the
world for good
for example years ago they saved a woman
who would later give birth to someone
who would prevent nuclear war
develop medical advancements etc for
every life they save it creates an
exponential effect shaping humanity for
the better
when you think about how old you are
the good you've done for humanity
becomes exponential
nile ends up saving the team and before
the final confrontation with merrick
andy tells nyle that losing her
immortality was no coincidence
nile was brought into her life to make
her remember that there are still things
worth fighting for
you reminded me they're people
still worth fighting for niles
sacrifices herself by standing in the
way of andy getting
shot and throwing herself off the
building with merrick
and he has gone from not giving a [ __ ]
about the world to basically threatening
copley in one of the final scenes to
help them fulfill their purpose of
making the world a better place this is
all a setup for a sequel which begins
with the excommunication of booker as
punishment for his betrayal booker is
forced to live
a hundred years away from the old guard
this is actually a pretty big punishment
since the old guard have been his only
family for the past couple hundred years
and now he's going to have to say
goodbye to them six months later booker
has turned to the drink and comes home
to see quinn
one of the original members of the old
guard the one who apparently went
crazy after being locked in an iron
coffin and drowned for centuries forced
to die over and over again it's kind of
ironic then that when we see her she's
drinking a glass of water
and he has always felt guilty for
quinn's fate she promised to look for
quinn but they never
found her now here's a spoiler warning
for chapter 2 of the comic
which hints at where a sequel would
likely go in the comic quinn's character
is known as noriko and becomes the main
villain
she wants revenge on andy for leaving
her to die although in the book she's
thrown off a ship during a storm the
iron maiden is totally cooler she'll
likely be teaming up with booker on her
quest for revenge although how she gets
him on her side remains to be seen that
being said an immortal who has gone
full crazy will likely pose a serious
hindrance for the old guard
especially andy who is now mortal thanks
for watching everyone be sure to leave a
like and comment about what you thought
of the old guard below
for more bad takes follow me on twitter
at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much